now I have enough pieces to graph this
guy right let's do it in exactly the
same way I went from naught to 360 okay
I'm gonna do that on this new set of
axes you
okay now you can see I've marked out the
dots for all of those 45 degrees 45
degrees 45 degrees I've marked them all
out but you can see I've only marked in
I've only labeled every second one I
just don't want my digester to be too
busy sometimes a diagram gets just this
so much stuff on there you're like I
can't even read this thing anymore sir I
want to put enough there to be
informative but I don't want to overload
it with information okay now your member
let the range of sine X was from
negative 1 to 1 and that's because
that's the range of the circle right the
units efforts from negative 1 to 1 we
are getting the exact same thing for
cosine right because it only goes from
negative 1 to 1 so I'm gonna have the
same range is negative 1 to 1 okay let's
go around the circle you can see the
order I'm gonna go in I'm gonna start
from you north up to 45 90 135 all the
way around I'm just gonna read off these
values and plot them on my breath so for
instance the first one Clause of 0 is 1
cos of 45 is about point seven so you
look at like we're halfway is and then
you go a bit further up something like
that cause of 90 is 0 135
okay how many of you guys did dr. Dodd
as a kid right I've got enough
coordinates you can almost even see the
path that it traces out okay carefully
maybe lightly in pencil if you're not
that confident to draw it smoothly and
then firm up when you when you've got a
better idea
join up these dots okay watch think
we're gonna get now we do have something
that at least so visually does resemble
and upside down
don't curve there are some differences
between them but you know you're getting
the general idea have a look at what
we've got starts at 1 it goes down to
negative 1 and then it finishes back at
1 and just for a second compare forever
all these things to note from science
right
smooth curve same deal stationary points
same deal except in this case we can
actually see three of them do you see
the three there's two high ones and then
there's a low one right they're not semi
circles again when you pop once you can
see it's still periodic every 360
degrees it's gonna repeat once I get to
heat I'm going back round the Cenacle
again so if you wanted to you could
continue this guy in both directions
right and lastly the range is still
negative 1 to 1 all these things we said
about sign they apply to cosine okay
what's the difference but if you look at
hard stare really hard and in fact if
you are if you can see right remember
Hydra these dotted lines to show it
actually continues right let me just
draw some dotted lines here stop it
there and then I'm going to hide this do
you recognize this graph this is sine is
it see exactly sine we just drew him
over there with one difference
what's the difference between this graph
in that graph yeah that's right
that guy starts at zero right but this
guy starts up the top if you like he's
kind of been
moved over I moved him over 90 degrees
you see that 90 degrees okay which
honestly we shouldn't be surprised by
because what does cosine me cuz there's
a cop Messer there's a deviation there
it stands for compliment right so from
that definition we said this do you
remember think back we read this thing
down yeah we wrote this guy down
now again how is a bit sneaky right
you're ever I asked you to draw two
parabolas at the beginning of the day
right two parabolas did your wife is x
squared everyone knows what that looks
like how would you describe verbally
what the difference is between this guy
and this guy and the answer is it's the
same guy just moved over a little bit
right the difference between this and
this is it's been moved over exactly two
units you see that you have a look at
this what's the difference between these
two and sup it's been moved over exactly
90 degrees it's the same shape right all
of the features are identical but it's
been moved over we call this V on a
technical phrase birth we call it phase
shifted right any of those traits notice
about phase and signals are that kind of
thing
yes ah that's a great question
which direction does it look like it
goes to you hmm
so for example if I click this shape
right and I want to end up with this
shape I'm going to have to move 90s lfsr
tight right because this spot here which
used to be at zero as I guess is going
to be at minus 90 so it's gone this way
90 degrees okay
now in the tune of course you get more
you see idea if you can move to the left
you can move to the right you can move
any combination of different distances
okay this particular cable is gone
dangerous boy
um it depends and this is something that
gets explored next to you it depends on
what's in here right I can change this
and I can make it move to the right I
can change I can make it move to the
left in exactly the same way I can do
the Prados right for example if I wanted
to move this guy to the left
I'd like this this is exactly the same
as this but instead of having a root at
the origin it'll have an at negative two
which is to the left